Hello. You may not know this from looking at me, but I am plagued with an
unfortunate circumstance. You see, I'm nearsighted, which means the lenses in
my eyes are a little, shall we say, overzealous, and they bend light just
slightly too much. Since the light does not bend around my retina, my world is
a blur. But of course, with every problem, there is a solution. By placing a
diverging lens in front of my eyes, I could fix my faulty vision. And to think
for years I was condemned to wearing glasses. Me. In glasses.
[LAUGH]
How passe! How cliche, I thought. I was as appalled then as I'm sure you are
now, but, I did find a solution with Odin's eye monocles. With Odin's eye
monocles, I can fix my vision with style, one eye at a time. It works with
farsighted people, too. So, if I have trouble reading as I age, I can simply
buy a converging lens to fix that problem as well. But, I know what you might
be saying. What about your depth perception? How can you gauge distance if you
only have one eye working at a time? Well, I laugh at your childish notion of
binocular depth perception, for I have discovered that monocular cues have
served me just fine. By looking at the relative size of objects or taken
advantage of linear perspective or interposition. I have been able to gauge
distance quite well. Quite well, indeed. &gt;&gt; [SOUND]
&gt;&gt; Odin's eye. It worked for me. Will you let it work, for you?